I couldn't have felt any older watching
the last dance as we know I in there in
episode 10 with my my my hair my flowing
mane and some people like Costas what's
the same David Aldridge the same thing
from the athletic the David my friend
David Aldridge da here on the Rich Eisen
show have an eighth aged a day
d8 not a day Richard it's good to know
that your TV isn't working very well
have you been are you are you well
everybody in your family well I hope
David I'm knocking on wood here well
yeah I mean there's no coping stuff
there's some other stuff but that's you
know it is what it is everybody's
dealing with something so but so but
nothing would regard to the virus so
that's at the blessing with older
relatives especially and you know just
trying to I don't know navigate these
unchartered waters no I understand I
understand again and I came on the air
and I said I hope everybody's seeking
justice and peace finds it immediately
and I'm assuming that's what you are
referring to yeah and it's just you know
I guess for the purposes of this show
it's just another reason why you know I
think people seek out what maybe we're
gonna be talking about in sports world
and and the last dance was so successful
to just lose ourselves and forget about
what's going on outside David yeah you
know yeah yeah it's hard part of I wrote
today that it's very difficult right now
for me to be you know all about sports
you know sports as important and we need
to get back and open everything up it's
very difficult to have that kind of
discussion right now you know everything
that's going on in our country and I
understand believe what I'm sure you do
too rich we all understand that sports
are important to people they're
important to us they're how we've made a
living
you know time pain like this I get it I
understand I've made a living covering
sports for a very long time as if you
and we get that and we know that it's
important to a lot of people it's
important to us right I mean it is I I
want I want sports to come back
certainly and I want the games to come
back because I do think it will help it
will help a lot of people but I know
that it's also you know there are people
who aren't thinking about that right now
and I just I would just like people to
be cognizant of that to know that you
know entertainment and distraction and
all those things are not things that
everybody has in the front of their
consciousness right now right no I
understand we can all understand that
that I think it'll go a long way toward
a lot of different things well then I'm
particularly thankful of you taking the
time today to call it I didn't take it
to that but I just wanted to at least
acknowledge and and and in respect what
you've just said Oh with at least me
saying that you know I appreciate that I
do very much so it's hard it's hard no
question about it David you know and and
again but that's why I'm appreciative of
you calling in David Aldridge of the
athletic here on the Rich Eisen show
where do things stand best you can tell
because we did hear from the NHL this
week a format man you're seeing baseball
having all sorts of collective
bargaining arguments it seems that's
bubbling to the surface where are things
with the NBA it's Union and an
announcement or for readiness to to play
again I think the the NBA Union
situation is much better in terms of
cooperation with the league than the
baseball unions is I mean that that just
seems to be spiraling you know out of
control in baseball the the basketball
union is working pretty much fanning
love the league I mean there's a
a joint committee that's trying to come
up with different scenarios so they're
not anywhere near finished yet but they
are working together you know the union
is basically signed off on you know
Orlando as the site of a playoff
you know tournaments however whatever
format that ultimately becomes the
baseball the basketball players put
money into escrow for the use of the
owners in case the season were to be
cancelled for whatever reason that so
that so the owners have some sort of
financial certainty in terms of their
losses being you know stanched somewhat
right for the rest of this year so there
and the biggest thing rich is that both
the you know the players and the owners
both want to play they both want this to
continue they want the season to
continue and they want it to conclude
with closed season play and having a
champion so my experience with legal for
many years is that when the players and
the owners both want something to happen
it tends to happen and so I think that's
why you know there's there's a lot of
optimism bordering almost uncertainty
that there's going to be you know a
resumption of play at some point
probably in July that would last into
September at some point before it
concludes with the finals any idea if
it's a to city to Hub City or one Hub
City anything of that I mean I think
right now I mean I know there's been
talking you know about Houston as a
possibility but I you know I know that
that you know Bob Iger has been pushing
very hard for Orlando and Disneyworld
and again I think the the players in the
Maine ever you're not going to get a
hundred percent support on anything the
thing in the main most most players most
of their agents there are some mages
still holding out for Vegas for
different reasons but most people are
all pointing in the direction of Orlando
now you know what's again the shape of
that will be determined by how many
teams are in the tournament
how many regular-season games you play
do you play all those regular-season
games in Orlando do you play them
off-site somewhere else you play with
another city that's maybe where
city comes in but I think the coalition
behind having your playoff tournaments
with however many teams qualify in
Orlando has pretty much been signed off
on by all the although all the important
parties as well I'll tell you this if
I'm a player with a family and I got
kids and I want to bring them into the
if you use the phrase bubble community
Disneyworld wouldn't be a bad place if
everybody can be let me know they're
they're safe that kids the kids can do
that Wow while dad tries to win the
Larry O'Brien trophy I mean that that
would be something I'd be more inclined
to do attempt yeah and that's part of it
that is definitely part of it is that
there's just more for family for the
families to do for them for the for the
kids to do for the even for the players
to do on all days and you can go play
golf in Orlando and and all you know on
an off day true on one of their 87 golf
courses right there you know right you
know whereas Vegas you know it's not
that it's not that Orlando isn't hot in
the summer it is nothing it's not humid
it is but it's not 107 like it was
yesterday in Vegas you know to be sure
you can't go outside in Las Vegas in the
summertime you can't you know like
there's not much to do that doesn't give
you you know heat stroke so you know I
mean you've got a you know so that's
where I think a lot of people are
leaning more towards Orlando than Vegas
even though Vegas in some ways probably
has more experience and would be easier
to control a hotel or at least a a chain
of hotels you know if you had the Wynn
and encore if you had Mandalay Bay and
all you could probably control that a
little bit more but there will be far
less for families to do David Aldridge
athletics senior NBA rider here on the
Rich Eisen show and so what what about
the format are are you hearing because
you know you you already hear someone
like Steve Kerr saying he's figuratively
on a beach right now like that word
they're done and then you hear Damian
Lillard and I think he's every right to
say I don't want to leave my family and
my home or even bring them across the
country if I'm just playing out a string
like you want to put me in
chairman where I've got a shot where I
can I can do my Dame time stuff then I'm
in where does that stand right now do
you think David I think if you you know
to to kind of you know generalize in
terms of where they are I just think
more people want more games right so my
guess is you will have some sort of
tournament type of playoff format where
whether it's one team whether it's two
teams per conference and you wind up
with twenty teams in this thing or you
come up with some way where everybody's
involved now I'm not I've been asking a
lot of people last few days well Golden
State's already been eliminated from the
playoffs how do you unlimited the most
dangerous 15 seed in the history of 13
play Thompson's healthy right I know you
want compelling programming you want to
playoff you want dying in the class I
get it you know what I mean and there's
a basic fairness here you did it's not
like you played five games and then you
shut the scene then you played 65 okay
like you played most of the season you
played 80 plus percent of the seasons
already so there has to be some sort of
fairness with regards to that those that
percentage of the season meaning
something you know it doesn't have to
mean everything but it should mean
something right I think there's a I
think the argument of the Milwaukee's of
the world is somewhat compelling we did
play a lot of diseases yeah we were
really good for most of that yes yeah we
should be able to take some of that
advantage to the postseason and I and I
tend to agree with that
so I think it will be I don't think it
would be all thirty I just can't see
that I don't know how you can other than
other than them playing those five to
seven games at the you know to get to
you know that they have obligations to
their local TV markets and their local
TV partners so everybody's got to get to
70 games so that they don't lose more
money you'll so you'll do you'll do that
right so all 30 teams will play to get
to 70 but how you then say that it's
okay for Cleveland in New York and
goldenface
Pete for a championship this year that
just doesn't seem right to me David
Aldridge here on the Rich Eisen show on
a few minutes I have left with you I'd
love to I've been conducting last dance
exit interviews for a lot of people who
now that now that it's all in the books
did you learn anything watching it I
can't say I learned anything and that's
just because I'm old and I was there
most of it I mean I you forget something
there's that's a different that's a
different point you know like I I did I
just forgot that Rodman just went to
Vegas a member I did forgot that he in
the middle of the finals just left to go
do a WCWS and it just kind of Remus eyes
to me you know what I think a phenomenal
job Phil Jackson did coaching that in
those three years because it could have
gone off the rails 100 times you know so
you forget things that happen
and I'm just when I saw people riches
I'm just glad that younger viewers and
younger people who like the NBA now you
know fans under 40 who weren't there or
they were infants when when that was
going on I have no recollection of it
I'm just glad that they have some sense
not only of how good Michael Jordan was
because he was that good and you
remember he was that good I mean that
we're not making that up he was one of
the greatest players it's not the
greatest player of all time right but
how competitive and dynamic the league
was in terms of the rivalries or the
passions and the hatreds and all of
those things that those teams had for
one another and and how compelling that
made the game and so it wasn't and what
I'm what I'm trying to explain to people
is that you know 85 84 could be a hell
of a game if they really hate each other
in every possession is a battle you know
I mean it's not just about it's not just
about you know shot efficiency all the
time you know the part of why some of us
older people really came to love the NBA
was because the competition was so
visceral and real
you know and and that meant and that
made it completely even though they
didn't score 115 points every day you
know it was still really fun to watch
those games back in those years
absolutely it was I did people get me
too and I do remember part of the
conversation being at the time and and
this is legit and now you look back
you're like what the hell are people
even saying like yeah but the Western
Conference was so weak when Jordan would
just win all the time right and then you
saw them then you also just saw to the
the the the the people who he beat he
beats magic he beats Malone in Stockton
he beats Berkeley and Phoenix he beats
you know Reggie Miller on the way and he
beats Patrick Ewing every single damn
time and then he beats Gary Payton and
the Sonics when they were terrific and
then you see you know though the Pistons
who he couldn't beat to start then he'd
vanquishes them on the way and the
number of people who every single time
I'd sit there I'm like you know what
every fanbase is gonna get theirs during
this 10 part documentary every fanbase
is gonna get theirs and then they showed
the trivia the number of 60 win teams
Jordan and the Phil Jackson and Pippen
Bulls eliminated numbers it's seven of
them sets an absurd number and absurd oh
by the way and Shaquille O'Neal in
Orlando he wound up taken out right -
right you know it really was just
remarkable in that regard but Oh last
one for you here was there a story you
told Jason here the director that you
thought man I would've been great if
they if they aired that that we didn't
see that hit the cutting room floor
Yuval you were in the middle of so many
great stories from the the the Fugazi
I guess slight that that Jordan created
his name escapes me the kid from the the
washing that brat breakfast just you
were you were telling all these great
stories was there one that you you told
that a man I wish had made the final cut
you know what a couple people that asked
me that rich and honestly I was
surprised
they used me way more than I thought
story told
David your great storytelling well
here's the thing like I did I was one of
the latter interviews that they did and
that's cuz a lot of reasons we just
couldn't find the time to work for
either of us for a long time
and so I thought and I'm not and I'm not
being like self aggrandizing it's about
this at all rich I thought okay they've
shot you know they've done a lot of
interviews they got all the tapes that
they're probably going to have you know
they're good but there'll be and you
know this being in television that you
television you have to cover it with
something right you like it you can't
you can't just show blank screen you
have to cover it with something so I
thought okay I'll be the guy that fills
in the gaps lists the stuff they don't
the games they don't have tape up for
whatever reason ice you know the
mainland so I'll be that guy and I'll be
in like two or three times over the
courses and you know what I was fine
with that
you know I was kind of expecting that so
I was pleasantly surprised they used
most of my stories if you if you were a
role player or a bench player for the
last answer or Vinny the microwave
Johnson man you were I mean I was happy
with it
okay complain about it that was great I
mean I really the whole thing from soup
to nuts was was wonderful and you know
at least at least what they did use of
you you didn't wind up on an iPad being
handed to Jordan because you didn't want
to be one of those people and the last
time to be on one of those iPads the
Jason hare handed Jordan saying check
this one out
appreciate the time David pleasure
always a pleasure talking right back
guys thank you thank you that's David
Aldridge hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here